- Some of you will be surprised to learn
that one of the hottest
products out there is slime.
Yeah, kids love to play with it.
And I am telling you because
it's in every single one of
the fibers of my carpets,
it's all over my house
and the thing that's
really interesting though,
about slime is it is an art
and there's a lot of social media on it.
A ton of tutorials.
This is like a real thing
and a movement out there.
And there's actually a really interesting
soothing aspect to it.
And when my teachers were telling me like,
please don't let your daughter
bring stuff in her backpack
with like squishies and slime,
it's very sensorial.
And so it's very soothing
to a lot of people.
And today we have a slime
expert to tell us more.
She's actually an amazing entrepreneur too
and I really, really love her story.
So please welcome teen slime
entrepreneur, Jay Kang.
Hi Jay.
- Hi Drew having me on the show.
- You know, we've actually
been really excited
about the prospect of you coming here
because you launched Snoop Slimes
when you were just 13 years old.
How?
- Well, ever since I was six years old,
I wanted to become an entrepreneur
and I would always write down on my,
you know, dream journal,
that I always wanted to
you know, own a business,
but I just never knew
when that time would come.
But you know, in the summer of 2016,
I was just scrolling through Instagram,
like a normal teenager.
And I found out that, you know,
these people are playing
with this stuff called slime.
And at first I didn't
really know much about it.
So I decided to do more
digging and research into it
and realized that people are
actually selling this product.
So I decided to ask my mom,
if she could help me invest
$200 into this business
that I want to start.
And, you know, in the beginning,
my sister was like, you know,
you can just get a fancy dinner
with those $200, you know.
But I decided to use those money
and invest it into the ingredients
that I needed to make my first slime.
And after that,
I opened my first Etsy shop.
I started my slime account on Instagram
and after two weeks I
started getting some sales
and it just blew up from there.
- I mean you have
a full on slime office
with four employees.
Four.
How does it feel to be
the CEO of a company?
- It feels amazing you know,
being able to have my own
schedule every single day,
being my own boss.
It's you know, so amazing
and also be able to be creative, you know,
waking up in the morning,
having to think of new slime ideas
and just being able to look
at so many different things
in so many different aspects of business,
like it's amazing.
And it's really difficult
to sometimes balance school, life,
and business life
and social life with my friends.
But with my time management skills,
I'm able to cope with all
those and work it all out.
- Well, will you teach me how
to do some slime right now?
I mean, by the way I hope
my daughters are, you know,
so savvy like you,
I'm going to love them
obviously, no matter what.
And I'm so excited to see, you know,
like my daughters already think
they know what they want to do
and maybe those dreams will stick,
but I love supporting them.
And it's funny because as
an adult slime is like,
it really gets messy in your house
when your kids are working with it
and I've always supported them.
I'm like play with the slime,
I'll figure it out,
I'll clean it up.
Okay so teach me, what did we do?
- All right Drew.
So we'll be making a
candy corn inspired slime
since Halloween is coming up soon.
So we're first going to pour
two cups of glue into the bowl.
- By the way,
I wish as this is what the slime
kit at my house looks like.
Olive just makes her own ratios,
it's all over the place.
I mean, she's like a mad scientist.
I call her the alchemist arsonist,
which I know sounds
like a really dark name,
but she really is.
She loves to get into everything.
- Yeah. It's all an experiment.
All right. Now we're going to add
one teaspoon of baking
soda into the same bowl.
- Done.
- [Jay] We can use a spatula
and we're going to mix both of
these ingredients up together
and just mix it thoroughly
you got to make sure
everything's just all mixed.
- Oh my God.
Literally I am in Olive's
happy place right now.
If we were playing with
like Barbies and princesses,
I'd be in Frankie's happy place.
- All alright now we're going to take some
contact slime solution.
- Yup right here.
- And you're gonna pour
just a little bit at a time
into the slime.
You don't want to make it, you know,
you don't want to pour too much in,
because it will make the slime too stiff.
But just keep pouring a little bit.
Don't pour too much.
There you go. Yup.
And then just keep stirring.
Keep stirring Drew.
- That's a contact solution.
Yeah that makes sense.
I see all these bottles
of like empty OptiFresh
all over the floor.
So yeah, that makes sense.
- Okay. I think we might need
to add a little bit more so
add little bit more
contact slime solution.
- Okay.
- You want the slime to
start getting off the bowl,
start unsticking.
- Oh, Oh, Oh, okay.
Oh God.
- Keep mixing.
- Okay. You know what?
By the way,
I think what we can do also
is like turn this into a workout.
I think maybe if you open a gym membership
to a slime factory and then we can, like,
the moms can help their kids
by working out their mom arms.
- That would be perfect.
All right keep stirring.
- Oh God.
- I think you need a little more.
- You know what, I'm I'm Oh, Oh,
can I please add these?
These are my favorite.
These are my absolute favorite.
Someone else made this wonderful slime.
Let's face it, I did not make this.
But I'm adding the
colored balls in, Oh God.
Now I'm going rogue, I'm fired.
- [Jay] Keep adding it.
- And I've got googly eyes.
I'm just, I'm going for it.
Cause we're going to commercial
and I'm like you know what?
My slime is getting everything.
How does this look?
- That looks amazing.
- Oh God.
By the way I'm not kidding.
If anyone has any interest,
please go on social media
and get into the slime world
because it is so relaxing,
it is so artistic.
It really is a very important
movement for people.
And like, it's so nice to meet you.
And it is so nice to see a
young woman such as yourself,
doing so much with your
life at such a young age,
you are such an inspiration.
And my daughter is going to
be so jealous of this segment
when she sees that I'm in deep trouble.
So do you mind if I a sidebar with you Jay
and maybe see if I could ever
like FaceTime you with her?
- I would love to send her any
slimes that she would like.
- Oh my God,
she'll be your biggest
fan Jay and we are too.
Thank you so much for coming.
(upbeat music)